[Music]
[Music]
look i think we wanted this nightwing to
be the perfect jumping on point for any
reader for any huge fan of nightwing i
believe in fan service i believe in
trying to give the fans what they want
as a fan myself i mean i have
nightwing sits right here on my desk so
i do like the men it's also
sort of taking everything i love about
nightwing and amping it up to that next
level showing the world why this
character is an a-lister nightwing is
the heart of the dc universe it's it's
said a lot he is this wonderful
character who just wants to look after
people
[Music]
nightwing was definitely a character
i've always wanted to write i never
thought i'd get the opportunity so when
when that offer came i was
jumping the appeal of nightwing is i
prefer positive characters i prefer
you know i'm not all about angst i like
hope i like inspiration
i'm not sure i can say what's different
but it's it's just like every time we
work together we've now been working
together i think something like 11 years
he is my favorite artist in the world he
is basically he's just my brother at
comics um we speak the same storytelling
language and have the same values when
it comes to story what you're seeing is
bruno just wanting to nail this
character he wants this one to stand
forever panel off the panel everything
is just beautiful and stunning and
effective and emotive i mean you feel
for these characters you feel for bads
you feel fit
[Music]
issue 87 is a grand experiment in comic
book telling what it is
is one continuous panel
from page one to page 22
we follow nightwing walking into a scene
and we follow him the entire way through
there are no panels
we it is one continuous story and one
continuous action which was incredibly
difficult to choreograph
it's um we we haven't seen this before
it was something that bruno and i have
wanted to do for probably a year and a
half we've been talking about doing this
together and this came up this idea and
this was the exact moment for it to
happen
[Music]
he's grieving but at the same time
alfred having left him
a mission in his will essentially he's
left him billions of dollars and said do
what i know you can do you know make the
world a better place with this look
after people i think that's inspired
dick to just go out there and do the
best you can and not necessarily as
nightwing not always in a costume
but as dick grayson
we wanted someone who was the absolute
antithesis of nightwing that's where we
wanted to start so
we've always heard that knifing is the
heart of the dc universe this is
literally a character called heartless
this is a character with no empathy with
no heart who collects hearts
usually from parents of homeless
children orphaning kids in the process
like this is as dark as it gets
and he is he's enhanced as well he's
very strong and very cruel so what you
have is you have the kindness of
nightwing you have this character who
helps everybody he can and the cruelty
of this character that's coming in and
you haven't seen what he's capable of
yet what he's going to do is
scary
if you've read issue 83 you'll know that
their relationship has just changed a
little bit or just stepped up a bit
there was um there was a kiss there was
a moment and we're coming into fear
state too in the in the batman books
with the the giant crossover event
where they're going to be thrust
together even more so
something
babs is being attacked personally by the
anti-oracle and dick comes to help um
nightwing
leaves bloodhaven even though he's just
announced that he's gonna do everything
he can to help this city but barbara
needs him so off he goes and he goes to
tackle this person who's threatening
everything that barbara's ever built and
of course she teams up with him
[Music]
i mean how could you not love
a three-legged puppy that's saved by
bullies and then has
two superheroes fall in love with her
she's somebody who brings the two of
them together brings babs and dick
together and also
gives
gives just unconditional love to dick
which i think he could use a lot of
it's nice that when he comes home
there's somebody waiting for him every
night and he has something that he has
to be responsible for that isn't just
his you know something outside his own
head someone someone who needs a walk
and needs feeding
but yeah haley is she's a wonderful
member of the fat family now
[Music]
you